[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to chicken so sick I don't
know so this is like so six house this
is like a visual novel of some sort and
I'm not sure what it's about but it
looked so delightful that I couldn't not
play oh hey so I'm so sick it's kind of
like sausage but not okay what's your
name oh my name is Mark yeah great to
meet you mark - meow oh great to meet
you - sausage welcome to my home
me my friend chukar trying to set up a
detective agency we've been watching a
lot of crime shows and since we can spot
the killer sometimes we think we've got
some real talent we're just working from
home for now hopefully this works out
for us
oh and one thing you should know about
Chuck is that she's dead she's a ghost
don't worry she's not scary she came
with the house in the catch with ghosts
is that only the homeowners can see them
so I didn't know it was haunted until
after I signed oh hi hey who's this say
hello to me hi I'll go and get the cow
down the wall for us I'll go fetch a
ladder I think he likes a chat okay be
careful in the ladder hey did you know
sausage it's famous I'm not lying
Oh sausage used to be this big child
star the face of multi meow there were
jingles and everything sausages face
plastered on billboards everywhere
sausage earned a wild amount of money
enough to be comfortable forever oh hi
hello
but sausages teen years were not kind
and their face just sort of kept on
growing
Oh eventually turning them into this
weird gangly spaghetti cat so now that
just kind of roll about looking for the
new fab to entertain them Hey okay got
the cow down hey more cat meow come and
say hi to the cow is that is that Margo
hi hello hey cow how are you doing you
look well today cow been working on any
poems lately I know that's what you were
doing last week hello new person now
these two times Souls been good to you
cow is an odd way with words don't worry
about it he was pretty aggressive when I
first moved in he would make the walls
bleed and make me see things but we
learned to live together
it's nice since cow is technically dead
too he can see me so I have two people
to chat to they take me out of the house
sometimes and wheel me around the
supermarket we are a happy family now I
love to ride in the trolley oh you're so
cute you sure do I think he's getting
overstimulated we should put him back
we love you cow okay sausage I think you
need to pop them back on the wall now
have fun you guys
is oh come on cow you need to go calm
down
alright see you later cow I have no idea
what's happening and I don't think you
do either
but I love it okay how about we explore
the neighborhood yeah let's go
[Music]
I want to explore the mystical circle
stone circle a let's see what's
happening over there okay I don't know
why hello why are you here a party this
is a pretty weird place for a party in
fact I'm pretty sure that's a skull up
there that I can see he's got a glass of
wine milk he's having a good time if you
say so
Oh greetings brother how's it what's
going on oh you're just in time tonight
we give thanks to the great water I love
parties this is great
I might have to nip back to the house
for though for some chips and dip yeah
hey sorry I'm late where the heck are
you
you were gone for hours do you have at
least the goat man this was the only one
left I think it might be an alpaca
I hope that's okay I mean they look
fairly similar looks pretty sweet right
I like it oh no no no this won't work at
all what why to summon the blood guard
we need actual blood and this doesn't
leave candy comes out that sort of
counts it's sort of symbolic okay I
don't know why don't we ask him oh I'm
so sorry that we your lowly disciples
couldn't get you the crimson wine of
darkness but will this pick-and-mix
suffice instead oh great one well when
you put it like that of course it won't
do fine I'll go back into town then no
it's too late for that we'll have to
improvise our new friend might be able
to help
I can help you must certainly can how
would you like to be a part of something
so much greater than yourself to be part
of a cosmic event a millennia in the
making that does sound important
it sure is sausage it's very very time
to go home I don't like this the style
of the old ones
we must crown your head with it but a
quick see it fits like a dream the beads
of perpetual uncertainty worn all around
the neck so stylish oh yes yes yes yes
you look like a God look I'll go set up
the table come approach the table with
me I'll just mock you with an X right on
your chest oh good the X helps me a ton
my aim is usually terrible with these
knives okay well now we know about that
let's try to skip to where we need to go
Scoob bloop my name is Mark a bloop
[Music]
let's have a wander in the forest what
could go wrong I suppose this is the
lantern force of the neighborhood when
someone dies a lantern appears in this
forest somewhere in the trees for a
ghost to pass over them ascender the
force and find their Lantern returning
their memories and bringing them peace
for some goes this is an easy task and
they feel a strong draw to their Lantern
Chuck has been looking for a lantern for
15 years man it must be somewhere oh I'm
sorry
okay we were at the street last time
let's carry on is it now I'm not feeling
it you sure yeah like I said it's
supposed to be a real strong feeling
like a wave smashing a brick wall it's
supposed to be totally unmistakable how
about this one but I don't want you to
go Juke not that one either hey what if
someone's stolen your lantern - then I'm
stuck here forever
cheers sausage you know just what to say
you're welcome I try my best
oh this one nope hey check out this
sweet cash Lantern oh my oh we did it
Rou so much money we'll live like a Lord
and Lady this is the last time right
Chuck
no more bank robberies I don't think I
could handle this anymore
yeah sure this is the last one oh man
but the thrill rue
d not feel it can't really say I do chip
my love no they caught up with us
damn they're fast but don't worry roof I
can drive like a demon they'll never
catch us please just let this be the
last time oh rue are you okay what
don't you guys pick up and shot does it
look bad
what no no it's just a scrape you'll be
fine we'll patch you right up you'll
have a scar and it'll make you so badass
I'll have to fight the other women away
from you I feel pretty dizzy chook what
you stopping down you're my main man rue
you bastards took rue but you can't take
me I die on my terms
oh I remember I remember everything
including how to rob the largest new
bank in New Zealand sausage get the
truck
sure thing chook chook rides again hey
not bad I guess I'll take it we'll take
it I think there might just be one more
ending to go oddly enough my name is
mark it mark that's my name don't wear
it out okay okay let's go into the house
let's go to the mansion whoo so this is
the spooky mansion huh why is this place
so spooky anyway it doesn't look all
that different from our place it's the
random screaming noises and people going
missing inside and stuff sounds like a
mission for us let's go inside I don't
like this does it the get out the stay
out the no and don't open door looks
like something was trying to get a
message across I just can't understand
it
you think they wrote it on the tendon
tons all over the walls and in huge
letters yeah I'm scared ooh I want to
see I want to see I'm brave I'm brave
okay let's do this oh wow this isn't
good what's that all over the floor and
I like this one bit is that blood who
left all these TVs on Oh here's the
remote let me try this
Oh what channel is this why is it just
eyes sausage all those eyes are looking
at you turn it off turn it off I'm
trying to Oh what is that sausage it
kind of looks like you it does a little
bit yeah maybe it's one of my old TV ads
and it's just bad reception
let me try playing with the settings a
little bit hi hello it's
ARC sausage sausage it just talked and
it didn't sound like you we need to
leave huh really I don't hear it
I'm telling you it's spoken it's scaring
me I don't like the way it's watching
you I think it's working
it's getting clear sausage run hello i'm
mortals win what is this with the veil
weakened I can finally take your place
oh it's the dark applier ending
oh okay that's a little weird carrying
on is it still is it still shadow so
high well welcome back oh heck what was
that hey welcome back remind me what was
your name again
my name you forgot my name it's freakin
markiplier duh great to meet you oh boy
okay hang on let me let me just see I
don't know if it's gonna change actually
but I wanted to just go one more time
into the mansion because it was it was
the only pool please can we just go to
the pub instead oh whoa don't skip
don'ts get much better oh nice looks
like we're just in time for the pub quiz
oh man I'm so good at quizzes
okay quiz time what shape Lantern
belongs to chook oh I know that one a
cache one sweet we know this what kind
of bird runs the circus the circus I
don't know about this circus what are
you talking about the circus a man for
me in the mansion there's a room full of
what televisions the electric bill must
be wild in that place the cultists are
hanging out of which location the stone
circle they just can't get enough of
rocks in a round formation why can't
sausage get modeling work anymore this
is both reasons above and more
I'm sat right here sorry
okay here we go let's see how we did
ah damn looks like those badges over
there one where the winners not us
damn Badgers but they were cheating I'm
gonna head home it was so close almost -
lantern a2e
gosh do I hate him mansion full
televisions uh stone circle both reasons
above tell me I got it
I think we might have done really well
I'll be blonde a holiday for two this is
the best book with ever hey very best
most wonderful ending oh oh they had to
bring the cow because Jukes a ghost
so I guess trooper technically wasn't
there but that's so cool
[Music]
everything about that was awesome
everything about that was delightful and
awesome ah in Frick yeah I mean it
wasn't very in-depth but the art was
delightful the music was wonderful the
story was funny and fun and a dark
applier ending it frickin works in
everybody's book so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought of this down in the comments
below and whoever made this let me go to
the about page made by to keep aloo ki
hey make more this was super awesome I
love this I think everyone out there is
gonna love it let us know what you
thought of it down the comments below
and thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]